let me give you an example of a failed
economy it wasn't because of the economy
failing but it still created a failed
economy the country of Iraq okay you
remember there was a guy running it
named Saddam Hussein and he had money
over there paper money with his face on
it and you could use the Saddam Hussein
whatever it was called right the Iraqi
whatever and you could use that you know
what that money you know what two pieces
of paper with Saddam Hussein's faces on
them are worth right now zero they are a
souvenir I've got a few of them some
special forces guy brought me some some
of those back just for fun but they're a
souvenir is there bars of gold being
used to exchange your little gold coins
being used to exchange and run the
economy in the country of Iraq now no
there's a new medium of exchange called
the Iraqi dinar
very unstable because the freaking
country is very unstable but it's still
a completely different medium of
exchange they did not go to go that's a
failed economy when the economy fails
did they go to using gold no they did
not and neither were the United States
of America but you got bigger problems
if the United States of America
economics economy completely fails to
that point so that's a bunch of
conspiracy theory bullcrap is what
amounts to that you need to buy gold to
shore up in case the economy fails if
the economy fails you'd be much better
off buying water generators and bullets
that's what's real if the economy fails
to that level and so you're you know it
just it's ludicrous its childhood
nightmares is what it is that people do
this stuff based on so no you do not buy
gold and if you look back 50 years ago
has an average rate of return of about
two percent and as the economy gets
better Gold gets worse because people
quit buying gold on these false fears
and they quit buying it based on the
false greed
and that's their and so no I don't own
any gold I have one nice gold watching
two gold cufflinks and that's it I do
not buy any gold I don't own any barrels
of oil either and I don't buy silver and
I don't buy commodities at all I don't
like the volatility of it where if you
buy a share of stock and a company it is
volatile yes but nowhere near as
volatile as the commodities market and
the the rate of return on that share of
stock is actually based on real numbers
not just the whim of the supply demand
curve by that I mean if Apple makes more
money their stock price goes up if
homedepot makes more money their stock
price goes up there's something to base
the stock price on you can actually do
an analysis on it but with the commodity
you're just you just you know sticking a
wet finger in the air and praying and
it's a dadgum nightmare stay out of that
stuff one last thing if your financial
product is advertised on cable TV and
the ad runs between Snuggies walk-in
bathtubs and self-insert catheters you
probably have a bad financial product
think about it where are you seeing gold
advertised right there that's where you
see gold advertised right next to Fonzie
doing reverse mortgages and magnum p.i
doing reverse mortgages it's crap
financial stuff right next to the guy
who's going to save you from the IRS
right right next to the guy who's going
to what's the other one only one more Oh
get you out of debt free easy debt
consolidation ads do you have over
$10,000 in credit card but we can help
yeah all right
and everybody's looking to take a pill
and make their life better it's not
going to work boys and girls you got do
the work you got into work so if you see
your financial product being advertised
in the setting like that you probably
have a bad financial product just to
give you a heads up hey guys thanks
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]